good to be here man uh
hey hey
i got that massage baby i got a
tightness in my neck
i mean like just the damn devil hit a
damn just a jolly rancher in my neck man
it just
it feels real tight i mean tight tight
you know oh man
and i went over to the place you know
and
i'm not going to say that they're
chinese when you go in the place but
they are
they are vietnamese or
they're and ease let's say that they you
know there's no
there's no bones about it they are some
type of ease
you know they're having they probably
had soup for lunch i'm gonna say that
some type of broth you know and uh
and the ladies sometimes i've gone to
this place a few times
you know i'm out here in the central
east studios and
i've gone to this place you know a few
times and
sometime i get the you know the rough
girl is in there
you know the real that you know she's
that uh
you know she's kind of a hit man
you know i'm saying she's somebody if
somebody in the family's choking you
won't
you know you hope she's there because
she can help
you know she's that thick aunt you don't
want that slender aunt helping you if
you choking
you don't want your fine art there
you're fine aunt she ain't gonna do
she's gonna scream she'll probably
snapchat it you don't you want
you want that thick baby you know that
big lozenge of a woman
and that's what they had there these big
chinese lodgings of a
lozenge of of a lady you know it's just
damn i mean she really
her forearms had six arms in them you
know she's just real poignant
real real poignant man i mean she could
spit hard and probably wash a window
so that's where i'm coming at with that
and uh
and so anyway they you know they got me
on the
you know i don't like this a lot of the
massage places uh
you know they put you on this kind of
halfway
lean forward type of thing where
they can you know you they put your head
in this little
it almost remember in the old days you
know back in the
you know 1300s or whatever i don't know
1800 something dude
some teen hundreds and they had um
back in the old days they had sorry
might be a little hot there
they had the the thing the um
the barracks you know they put you in
they put your two hands in and they put
your head in it
and people would come by if you did
something bad around town
they put you in a town square and they
you know they put you in there and
people come by and
call your names call you you know
probably gay or something like that
you know devil boy [ __ ] like that you
know this i'm talking
13 1800s and
so you know when the kids come by and
probably tickle you
you know the pervs come by and touch
their nuts everybody
when you're in the barracks or in the
what is that called
barracks um
i think that's what it's called man
barracks
uh let me think when you're in the you
know what i'm talking about the cat the
barracks man
the barracks in town what is that thing
[ __ ] i don't know but it's the thing
they like it holds your head it holds
your arms you can't move
and people laugh at you and point
fingers you know
people say oh that's a little you know
you know that's a little uh ricky and he
did something bad you know
he stole a cabbage you know he stole
four cabbage
that's ricky with you know that's four
cabbage ricky and you then you're that
bad guy you know and
but anyway when you're in the barracks
everybody comes by and gets they
the people that want to name call they
name call you and the people that want
to tickle you and then
and the perverts that want to you know
touch you nuts or get a look at your
booty or whatever you know
everybody you know everybody gets it out
of their system when you've done
something bad and
um what was i talking about
oh so i know what i was talking about so
anyway i'm in there and they got me in
it's like that kind of thing you're kind
of leaning forward and the ladies behind
you and
i don't know if they found a tough spot
on my back but
they had uh the the lady is like pushing
on my back
and then she had like her cousin or
somebody her brother
daddy somebody you know another
[Music]
you know another miese or ease person
starts pushing on her so they're both
so she's pushing on my neck kind of back
and he's pushing on
behind her like leaning on her
and i'm just like you know like they're
trying to get just a a
a a friger frigidaire through a tight
doorway
and that [ __ ] i'll just i don't know
i never seen anything like that and
so anyway uh oh and then so then after
that i did 30 and 30.
you know they call that's a um 60 minute
package that's package b
that they have there on the chart and
and so the second half they get you in
uh the private room you know and they
have some um
fake roses in there and a little
they got these coca-cola candies they
are so good they're
these little hard kind of candy you suck
on them but
so i put two or three in my mouth when i
go in because i do the one hour service
so anyway
and the lady and sometimes
i think it's just tradition in a lot of
the east
you know you go to some places and they
bust you out
you know they cream you out right there
bro and so
the ladies you know she's doing my body
and everything and i'll get
i won't get fully new but i'll get down
to my underpants easily
dude i'll get down in underpants if
somebody says hey you want me to scratch
your back
i'll be [ __ ] you know i'll be 94
naked baby you know what i'm saying i
for any
if a good television program is on off
you know and it's a half hour program
i've been like that since i was a child
i would get so fired up man and just
when the
pressure builds and the plot thickens
i'm damn just start losing
you know i lose pieces of clothing till
i'm just damn naked just
i mean and i'm just clamping on my wing
just
just watching the what's going on you
know i'm just
i'm locked in i looked at it i say no
i'm locked in baby and uh
and anyway so she uh the ladies um
she goes uh uh you wanna spill a dumplin
and i'm like what does she say and i she
goes you wanna spell it duncan
spell it duncan and i'm thinking speller
dunlan
uh i didn't know what it was you know
i'm thinking is it something
and then i'm thinking oh it's nothing
you know because i didn't know what it
was and she's you know then she kind of
pats me on the on that peony you know
what i'm saying that peanut bruh
that penis and then she tapped me double
tap me on that penis you know
and uh and she said spell it dumping
and then i'm like oh spill the dumplings
she wants to spill the dumplings bruh
and
and you guys know me look i don't like i
don't like somebody
you know i've been hell i've been
spelling i've been
battling my dunlins all week bro i spent
my dumplings spelt
i spilt them matches you know and i
shouldn't have been
and i did man i gave in and i've been
jerking myself so i
you know i don't know man i don't talk
about but uh
anyway i just i said no you know i was
cordial i was a gentleman
you know i kind of went like this you
know no
and um and she wasn't offended
and that's one thing i love about a lot
of asian cultures they don't get
offended if
you if you if you don't if you don't if
you don't want them to jerk you off
you know and a lot of other people get
all you know white people be like oh
come on you know come on you know
oh okay i guess well all right you know
black people be like oh okay oh you all
right
you ain't gonna let us bust them nut you
know what i'm saying everybody in
german people were like oh you
but asian people they don't get offended
man that you know
it's just part of life it's like it's
like a handshake
forget it you know and uh
anyway i don't know that's just you know
there's trying to spell it nothing bro
you know and i didn't i didn't want that
dauntless spill man
i didn't want my dumplings spilt man so
that's kind of i guess what's been going
i mean i don't that's what's been going
on
but uh but that's what happened another
time i remember i was at a joint out
there in los angeles
and a lady tapped me they double tap
that's the thing it's like knock knock
on your uh right on you on your uh
penis you know on the top and uh
and i said she goes oh you won oh monkey
go pop pop
and i was like monkey go pop up
uh and i said no no i'm okay you know
and then i reconsidered and i was like
well
uh and then the lady's looking like i'm
just like this indecisive
person which i am so
anyway man you know it's just you can't
go anywhere these days without somebody
really trying to cream you out you know
but um but thank you for being here with
me today man it is uh
thursday february 11th in uh
in the year 2021
and i'm doing my best man and i hope
that you are let's get into a little bit
of tunes
sing down the sun oh that's a good song
baby
shine down your song
come on baby so that it might
guide me back home this is josh kelly
we all need some light
amen on the darkest of days
[Music]
it's a holy holy holy lord holding my
heart
down on my knees asking you to hold me
hold me hold me with your
[Music]
[Applause]
i lost all my joy
[Music]
let's go
holy holy holy lord holding my heart
down on my knees asking you to hold me
[Music]
oh man dude that one had me gleaking
right out my feeling ducks brother
that's when god hit me right in the damn
hvac of my
of my soul brother and my tear ducts man
beautiful song right there
off his new album my baby and the band
that is called hold me my lord by
josh kelly featuring all voices
um if you're not familiar with josh
kelly man go
go go get that album and get familiar
with him and uh
i'm sure a lot of you guys are but go
get familiar with that song
um he's a friend of mine and and
uh and he actually gave me a job i i
worked as a tour manager for him
when he first uh when he first started
touring
with his music and um just honored to be
able to play one of his songs here today
oh what's going on man
what is going on um
yeah i went to the place i did that oh
i'll talk about this the super bowl
happened
you know i was uh it was a boring game
you know it was a boring game and um
[Music]
and i think a lot of people were just
shocked kansas city didn't put anything
together
uh and i don't know what you attribute
that to attribute that to
but it was it was it was nice to see tom
brady it was nice to see somebody
you know get away from the system that
new england system and do something
you know it's nice to see an older
person get out there and be a rascal and
be
randy and do confidence
and man that made me feel really good uh
um i went over to michael chandler's
house ufc michael chandler fighter man
you know hit
he came on here and uh
and you know i snuck that dustin poirier
freaking sauce into the party son
loyalty is going to loyalty and um
and i felt honored to go over there and
just be it it was fun man to talk about
fighting a little bit
and to be able to watch uh watch the
super bowl
um what else happened
i did a comedy set last night and it was
one of the best shows that i've had in
about a year
so i'm drinking a little bit of tea
right now um
my throat has been a little bit rocky uh
but yeah what else what else what else
have i been doing
my i hurt my neck so i've been trying to
take care of that and that's why i was
getting the um
the massage over there that's why i was
getting massaged
so um
what else oh i heard a badger
out back at a rental i'm in an airbnb
right now
you know doing um rental living they
call it
and that's rental living where you're
somewhere but
you really don't want to be there and
that's rental living
and so i've been doing that and uh and
last night i heard a
around like i was like i heard an animal
so i look out there and it seemed like a
cat but the way he walked was more
almost like a like he was
like his paws was kind of hot
and i said well surely somebody didn't
heat a cat up and just let it loose out
outside
you know or put fire by a cat and then
you know make it run
um so i said it must be a different
animal then i heard it make a noise
i heard it do some uh howling or
whatever
and that's when i knew oh okay
something's going on here um
and so i i was i was started looking up
different animals
sounds on the youtubes
and what i found that it was was a
badger
listen
yup
[Music]
you hear that like they swallowed a
balloon like a helium balloon and they
and they [ __ ] bro doing sex listen
again
[Music]
oh yeah that's like somebody freaking
you know you know sometimes the clown
will fold up that balloon for you and
they'll hand it to you and
you know if you gas that thing out
sometimes you
you know you pretend it's cute it's a
flower it's a crown when mom and dad are
around
then you sneak off behind the barn and
gas up
and then you try to uh you know
then if you're doing sex or if you just
um
you know doing hula hooping anything
where you got your body moving with that
gas in it and you'll sound a little bit
like this
[Music]
oh oh that's bad now that that one's
angry man that fella got angry about
something
um but yeah we got we got some good
calls that are in
what's going on with me not much i'm
just honored to be here
be here today man um you know i've been
going through some tough stuff in my own
world
and i want to kind of talk about that a
little bit uh
you know um you know i
i fell off of my sobriety about a month
ago
and so i've just been you know just been
battling to kind of get back
on that train um
and i wanted to kind of talk i wanted to
talk about it on here but i just
the timing was kind of never right and i
don't like to
i don't like to have to report to the to
the podcast every week about
you know how i'm doing it with uh with
sobriety because i don't want
you know me and my and
i don't want any of my sobriety
to be like something i like that i then
have to like like i feel like an
obligation to the podcast i don't ever
want to have to feel that way
because it doesn't it won't help me uh
in my journey with being sober it just
it won't help me um
so i haven't been doing anything batman
i was just in a lot of pain and i didn't
want to take pain pills and
i'd fallen off of going to my meetings
and uh
and so i just i i i drank and i just
found that drink
drinking was helping me deal with the
pain better
um then pain pills i just i don't want
to take pain pills
and if i had a beer i could manage
it was just easier you know i could have
half a beer or something it would take
the edge off a little and and give me
some relief
um so
you know things i've been doing now
we're trying to have a meeting here at
my home
um you know been staying in contact with
my
with other people in the program um
and
i don't know i i guess i was a little
like
you know i know we have some listeners
that that are sober and so i
i didn't i guess i was afraid some that
you know that they would judge me or um
i don't know
yeah they would think i i don't know
what i don't know what i thought i mean
i guess
i guess yeah i guess i was just afraid
of being judged or something but
um you know i haven't been like
scared i haven't been putting myself in
in bad instances
um but you know i definitely
you know i'm just trying to you know get
back on
the the best foot um
so that's kind of where i'm at with it i
guess
uh you know so i just
wanted to be honest i hope i'm not
letting anybody down you know i'm just
it's just you know i don't know it's
just a journey and i i
and this is where i'm at and so i can't
be ashamed of where i'm at or anything i
don't feel ashamed
um you know i just
i want to i want to best put myself in a
situation
for me to be um
you know the healthiest that i can be
and the best that i can be in in most
regards
you know i can we can only be so best
you can't be 100
best you could be maybe 70
um so i'm glad i said it i i was kind of
scared to say it and uh
and you know i've been having a lot of
fun in the episodes the past couple
weeks and so i didn't want to
kind of make it a downer or anything um
but you know i appreciate you guys just
you know uh being a part of my life um
and yeah i'm just happy to be here today
and uh yeah
so i still hang out at my my two best
friends here sober guys i still you know
i'm
i'm i'm surrounding myself with sober
guys and i'm trying to
just get back on the wagon you know and
i'm not struggling every day i'm not
running around drinking i'm not like
making uh you know putting myself in bad
instances or anything
um but i do have some fear
that you know that i could
so um
so yeah i don't know that's just where
i'm at
you know my friends know and uh
you know and and other people that are
in the program know and
you know i've long in my life i never
really felt like i had a problem with
alcohol
you know i never did i mean my problem
was always that alcohol could lead me to
do drugs
uh so you know i've never been somebody
just gets
just black i just never did that i don't
like drinking that much because you have
to go pee a lot
and i'd rather not pee i'd rather sit
there and just you know keep watching
the program
but uh yeah i don't know maybe i'm
making too big of a deal out of this i'm
just trying to
share with you like kind of where i'm at
and and some of my fears
and um and
yeah that's just what i'm trying to do
so uh
anyway you know that's kind of that and
that's what's going on uh with me right
now and
um and uh
and yeah so
um you know i've been picking meetings
back up and going online
and uh and
know i feel hopeful i don't feel like
scared i don't feel like i'm
spooked or anything but i just want to
be
honest with where i'm at
uh what else man um
oh yeah that badger was back there we
got a sound board in here now
we may we're just trying it out they got
some different sounds in here
this is my favorite damn chica for like
yeah yeah and so that is my favorite
um we got a couple of other ones dude uh
that white rain and that's frank giles
right there
um oh big announcement frank giles was
at the comedy show the other night
so i'm on stage at zany's and
and i'm looking around the crowd and i
see this suit
i see just this beautiful
this really this this mordor
snowman in a suit
and i said a joke and then i heard that
laugh
man that only that frank giles that
freaking
that rattle baby that death rattle
[Laughter]
and i said from the stage i said frank
and he said yes sir you know and it was
him dude
and everybody i was like oh my god
everybody is frank giles
you know and he's and he's here
and dude people were going crazy man
people were going crazy and so we did a
couple you know
we talked a little bit and talked a
little bit about the show and um
yeah it was just it was fun he came
backstage after and we had a good time
uh it was special man so i just want to
say thank you frank giles for coming out
and man we we
we had a couple more questions about
death back there we talked about
and it was good to get some of those
answered
and he even said he'd come back on
sometime and follow up with more death
answers and
and different answers like that so
um i want to let you know that uh
today's episode
is brought to you by liquid death it's a
mountain water
it's good today's episode is also
brought to you by
helix sleep and look
you know there there's a famous story
about the um
it's like the stepsister fell asleep and
they had somebody hit a walnut
under the sheets and she couldn't feel
it because she was
too beautiful but the truth is
that [ __ ] was on a helix mattress man
that's the real truth man
and um and and a lot of people you can't
sleep today because your wife got long
hair her hair will come over and get in
your eyes and your face
you know her hair is like a dirty river
and it comes over and flows right up
into your damn
uh snuff holes
or sometimes you um you know you can't
sleep because
uh the fan is making to get your fans
some people got a fan with a rattle and
they won't fix it
they won't fix it man damn chicken foot
they would rather just lay there and
just hear it every night
and be like i should fix it but they
don't fix it
so what you need now is that helix sleep
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to your perfect mattress
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
i don't know with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for you
and perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
they know that at helix
dang it they know it in some places you
go and they walk in they don't know
you go to a mattress shop they don't
even know what's going on they give you
a cup of lemonade
and say hey hey hey hey the move you'll
start in an
hour you're like what but at helix they
know you're looking for sleep
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm baby i go firm
firm baby i like to feel like two
chinese are pushing up against my skin
when i'm resting
oh it's great for cooling down if you
sleep hot and even a helix plus mattress
for plus
size sleepers and you know who you are
baby them
then plus size sleeper baby if you sleep
thick
boy they can help it's been awesome
getting massages but it's even better
getting that full-time massage from that
helix
i got to tell you right now just go to
helix sleep.com
theo that's h-e-l-i-x dot com
slash t-h-e-o helix is offering up to
two hundred dollars
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep dot com slash t-h-e-o
that's helix sleep.com theo for up to
off and two free pillows
you know when i sleep i kind of go
through this ritual you know i know i
like to put lotion on
and i learned that from my mother you
know i was raised by my mother
and you know that [ __ ] you that's joey
diaz said that i didn't say that
but um i was raised by my mother and so
she taught me at night you put lotion on
she taught me when you get out the
shower you do the uh
towel around your hair you know there's
just different practices
you know what i'm saying like i couldn't
use i didn't know how to use a hammer
when i was a kid but
i knew how to uh lotion up my legs
and do when i was young you had this
fellow bus he would let us he's a senior
citizen
you know and that's really the most
citizen you can get
and he would let us uh lotion his legs
man this older guy
you know mr birch and he was named after
the wood
and he would let us lotion his legs up
man and i don't know if he was
pedophile if he was pedophile it was
late onset because he never did anything
wild until just the very end
and he said i swear to god he went to he
went to heaven on some real
on some soft stilts baby because we my
god we must have put about six damn
gallons of lotion
onto his legs man praise god big birch
baby
you know and i'll tell you this he's the
softest standing birch
there is out there
and we really we really loosened that
man up
um what else is going on
oh so we had a guest on here recently
you know
and he got you know we got assault he
he got caught you know using racial
epithets
i think it's called i don't know the
exact term
but you know you're saying words you're
not supposed to say
and he said he would try to do better
that was a statement that he made and
and you know it's
i i wanted to think about it some and
just and
and it's not like you know
well first of all what makes me upset
what upsets me
what upsets me most is that there's
hatred in the world that upsets me
um i don't think this man was coming
from a place of hatred i think he was
you know i think he was using a word he
probably shouldn't have been using
and uh and you know you don't know where
somebody learns a word you don't know
where
these days you know it's on the the n
words on the radio all the time
not the radio but it's on music you can
go buy it you can buy it on itunes
you can go buy it um
and you know it's interesting because
uh because yeah it's that if you
call somebody that name and you mean it
and that and you say it towards them
it's
man it's hurtful you know when i could
easily see in people
of color how it would just how it's such
a word to demoralize you know
and to um
and to imprison in a space of of less
than
um but at the same time
it's it's crazy that the word is
available for sale
and and i'm kind of all over the place
here um
and i'm not defending anybody for saying
it i mean it's
you know you hear it i hear it all the
time i hear it all the time you hear it
from people
in these days when i when i was young
you would hear it
well i guess i would hear when i was
young growing up from people that were
racist and i would hear it from
music you know nwa and
and so it's weird because it's like a
word that's used in hip-hop culture
you know with the a at the end and um
and so it's just it's it's interesting
and i don't want to be afraid to like
think about things you know
but one thing that really made me upset
about
uh about the n-word is
the way that media outlets cover it
and the way that media outlets cover it
so somebody says it right
they take it and they make articles
that say at the top of the and these are
outlets that would never even
probably cover the person that if
there's a famous person that says it
you know uh you can be a white dude in a
starter jacket and say it all day you
could be six
nine and say it all day you know but if
you're popular and you say it the media
they cramp down on you
and what gets me um
is that they use it the media puts
inward
in the title of articles
so they get you to go click on it
and then you're reading the article
you're watching it or whatever it is
so they are making money off of it
and man that burns me up to think that
because then you and i bet if you follow
the companies
who is who's who are earning
money from the clicks and the people
watching or reading
i bet it leads right to white pockets i
guarantee you that
so man it's just crazy that people that
would never even cover this artist
at all or this celebrity at all suddenly
they're writing articles that are
clickable
that they're making money on so they're
basically
making money off of the n-word
they're making money off of it
and man that really i mean that just
yeah man that just makes it makes me mad
bro that make me just
mad dude make me feel like a damn just
like six badgers are climbing up and
down my spine you want to know what a
badger sounds like i'll tell you
[Music]
and let's get to the angry ones
that's what it makes me feel like you
know because you have companies that
don't care and now that
so they're basically you they are using
the n-word
to make money
and that's that man that burns me up it
just burns me up
and i think it should burn anybody up
you know
yeah and it's kind of wild in the media
like somebody can apologize first for
for for uh saying something they
shouldn't
somebody can apologize for using a
racial slur but the immediate they don't
want a
apology somebody could say well i'll do
better
but that's not enough for them
they want to just roast it they want to
take over they want to
they want you to burn
and that's just wild to me like
don't no matter what someone does don't
we want them to have a
don't we want them to feel
you know you want someone to feel
reprimanded
but don't you want some don't like what
if it was your kid that did it like it's
just crazy people would
ostracize so much and just denounced
like there's you are worthless
and uh like what do they want you to
kill yourself what do they want
do they want you to lose your own life
by your own hand
by a dagger by a sword
you know i just don't understand
sometimes
because somebody's saying they'll do
better i mean it's but i guess you know
you need to believe them
but man and then what if
and and what if don't any of these
writers who write these articles what if
your kid does something wrong one day
what if your husband your brother your
what if someone you
do you want them to be burned like that
i just don't i i don't know
and then it's wild that they'll say you
know it's like they shouldn't
we should they should just get rid of
the word
they should get rid of the word because
you could buy it online i mean website
is mapple music somebody whatever
platform they're making money
you could go listen to it you could buy
it
maybe white people shouldn't be allowed
to buy stuff with the word in it
if you sell somebody enough produce
you know when sometimes a strawberry
rolls out their mouth
you can't be shocked but you're the one
vending it to them
and i'm not saying that's the case in
this instance exactly i'm not saying
that but i'm saying that that's a real
thing
you know and i think there's a lot of
people out there of color who feel the
same way who are just tired of
the music that's like you know kill
these n words and all this [ __ ] it's
just
it's i don't know and look
i'm just a white person so i only have
my experience
you know i grew up around a lot of black
people i used to be in a group called uh
nfl and i can't say the whole name of
the group but i can say for life
um
dude i used to ride my bike in in the
school in the morning
and johnny smith and the boys they would
come and jump on my bike
and they would call me to a bus when i'd
come in they would call me the n-word
bus hey here comes the inward bus and
they would all pile on my bike
and i'd be sitting there just rolling
just a damn i mean literally the
basketball team
deep and now we just you know man my
dude my quads was beefy son
my quads was beefy you know what i'm
saying
damn chicka for like you know it
and they would call me the n-word bus
here come the n-word bus
and my parents didn't say it you know
my dad said it one time a black guy
stabbed him with a screwdriver and he
said it
so i'll be honest but um
i don't know man some of you know it's
it's just
like there's just a lot of red tape out
there but then look
that's only my perspective and i'm not
saying that it's right but i don't want
to feel like i can't think and talk
about it
um because i also know that it's a
hurtful word
you know uh but i also know that
the media just there's no court of law
there's just
the there's no examination of that kind
of thing of
of what was going on you know
and in this instance he called a white
guy it and i think mo i think a lot of
white people should be called it
honestly
you know maybe that's what needs to
happen maybe you need to line up a lot
of black people that want to say it and
a lot of white people that should be
called it
i don't know but
anyway man i i didn't mean to go off on
that i just
i don't know it's just it's you know it
was here in the central east
that's where you know i mean it's
everywhere
but i just don't understand sometime the
media is taken i don't like
that there's companies out there making
money off of it profiting
profiting off of it man that burns
that burns my bread man
but we'll get into a few more calls here
man i know that
and i'm gonna tell you right now that if
you're suffering from mental health
issues
which i am you know i missed my medicine
yesterday and then i get late at night
and
i can't remember if i took my medicine
and then i don't want to take it because
it keeps me up i can't sleep and then
i'm like dang
and then i wake up the next day and now
i'm feeling depressed and
you know if you take medicine it can be
it can be tough
well if you follow in times where you
where you need some help uh
better help can help you you know
if there's something something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you
from achieving your goals better help
will assist you
and assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional
therapist that's right you can start
communicating in under 48 hours
there's a broad range of expertise
available at better health
if you know if you've won a certain type
of uh mental health professional
you may want somebody that is your same
race or religion or
creed or i don't know what creed is i
mean it was a band but i don't know what
their
what they mean by that but you know
maybe if you can read or can't read or
somebody or
if you blind and you want to talk with a
blind
therapy then they can do all of that
better help want you to start living
happier life today
visit their website read their
testimonials betterhelp.com
theo that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over a million people have
taken charge of their mental health with
help of an experienced
professional you want a professional you
don't want somebody in a chef's hat
uh you know giving you mental help you
know what i'm saying you don't want
somebody
um on a surfboard giving you mental
health you want a therapist brother
in fact so many people have been using
better help they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
wow
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and this past weekend listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
theo
oh man um what else i wanted to write
i wanted to tell you they was um
[Music]
oh uh
i saw also they had uh
they had sexual allegations against
marilyn manson
you know and i don't know what the guy
did i don't know
but i would you know i don't know if he
i and i don't think he was messing with
underage women
i think he was dating of age women
but i'll say this some lady they said
she said they found out she had a sex
dungeon
and he was trying to hit her with a
wigwams or something dildos sorry
um
by looking at marilyn manson
that should give you a 99 idea
that this dude don't be
[ __ ] regular you know what i'm saying
he ain't [ __ ] regular
he'll put on a condom that has edgar
allen poe's autograph on the side of it
you know
you have to like
if you if you go to dinner with them and
they serve in vulture
you gotta think oh he probably gonna
have an extra dick or two on them you
know what i'm saying like
you can't look at that guy
and think that things are gonna be
regular i don't think
i'm not blaming anybody i'm just saying
you have to have like because the lady
said oh he was scary or something
but i'm just saying look
the dude is doing 365
days of halloween okay
this dude does halloween like a
instagram thought does her birthday
all right it's a two-month deal i bet
this dude probably [ __ ] you know
he'll probably
you know this dude got licorice under
his armpits for good luck i'm just
saying
you can't look at marilyn manson's
and expect that he ain't gonna be
skeeting asphalt or something you know
what you just you can't look at him
the dude looks like the saw movies
i remember i'll tell you this you know
and i've and i've had i've had a
i was almost molested you know or
semi-molested or whatever at a marilyn
manson show
they had a man this man uh richard
langenstein they called him dicky
and he was a senior citizen and he was
he had um what's it called when it looks
like you have snow on your arm
but uh it's like a
i think um scabies or something i don't
know what it is
hold on let me look it up
he had um
seven causes of white spots on your skin
mycosis bro i don't know if he had that
[ __ ] he ain't have that man
dermatite dermatitis eczema broth uh
maybe
yeah i think he had eggs in my bro i
think he had that
hypodemonicism sculler sclerosis
i don't know bro he was [ __ ] spotted
up you know what i'm saying he was that
speckled molester
you know he was that um he was that
uh you know he was that
you know he was that dicky dalmatian
kind of guy
well he took me and my best friend at
the time
patrick he we were 14.
we was 14 we met him through church and
he took us to the
marilyn manson show and dropped us off
in there
and dude it was 18 and over
and he took one of my friends to las
vegas i think it might have pedophiled
him i don't know
but but i do know and i think that's
what happened but um
but anyway what happened was hold on
so richard langenstein and he deceased
now human to jail for pedophilin bro
for p filing but um
was i telling you oh we went to marilyn
manson's
on stage he cut his friend open with a
beer bottle and the ambulance came
i remember being in the bathroom
my friend and i are peeing and it's
taking a long time
because everyone around us
smells like voldemort
and we're peeing as a guy behind me
eating [ __ ] charcoal briquettes bro
it's
the dark arts
and somebody said to someone else they
said man
these kids are pretty young to be in
here
and somebody else goes yeah somebody's
gonna
them tonight and they said f word [ __ ]
so anyway bruh uh
you know what was i talking about dude
is this for better help what is this um
i don't even know
it's just like but i know that when i'm
going to maryland
i know i'm going to i know
that i'm entering you know be
al's a bub's [ __ ] i know
that they gonna have crows in the
corners of the room
you know i know that if marilyn manson
spits on my back
that the that the saliva is gonna
slither off down my
arm into a drain and procreate a demon
i know
now i don't know everything
but i have some responsibility as a
human to
lightly assume that things are going to
be risque
and i knew that at 14.
but anyway man
let me hear from my freaking friend
again bro you know what i'm saying oh my
god
damn chicka fully yeah
you know what i don't give a [ __ ] you
know that
that's the madman himself man you know
that so that's fun
um let's get into some calls man i want
to thank you guys for being a part of my
life
and you know i know i say some stuff on
here that some people
might not agree with and that's okay
you know and uh it's okay if you don't
agree with me
i i probably don't agree i i i i'm just
trying my best i'm trying to think out
loud and
recently man i've been angry
and when you mix anger with trying to be
peaceful it's hard
you know when i'm just angry and
[Music]
and i don't even know why sometimes man
i don't know if i'm angry at myself
i don't know if i'm just angry at the
world it's a tough time right now
you know i called a friend the other day
and uh
and i was just telling him i'm angry
he's like man i'm so glad you said that
i'm angry
people's angry
you know and i stay away from the news
these days and that i think that helps
some
but it's amazing that the news will
never go on trial for
its crimes
imagine the people they read an article
and they believe it
right they believe it and they go out
and take some action and somebody dies
from that action or gets hurt or
you know somebody does it starts a crime
it starts a
i mean that started by media by bad
information by faulty information
people trying to get money
man we are in a canoe brother we are
rolling
through one of them haiti's tributaries
right now i feel that brother praise god
let's hear some calls that came in man
and um
you know and thank you guys for being a
part of my life and uh
and for sticking with me when i'm i
don't know i don't want to be right i
don't want to be wrong but i want to be
able to think out loud
and recently sometimes i get afraid to
do that
you know with all this canceled culture
out there you can't even think out loud
and if you have comments or thoughts on
anything i ever talk about you're
welcome to call in and share them
you know that 985-664-9503 is the
hotline
and uh if you need to take me to task if
you need to
share something that's on your heart you
know that's troubling you man i think
right now sometimes i'm scared
you know i'm scared of getting older i'm
scared of being in a new place
um
i'm scared of not being able to figure
out why i have a tough time really
loving people like in a real intimate
way that
you know i could start a home or
something like that or do a family
um i'm scared sometimes that god wants
me to do more for him
and uh not like he chooses me to do more
but just that he wants to
he wants me to be more part of his life
sometimes in some ways
or her life whatever god is you know the
goodness in the world whatever that is
you know i'm not i'm not sticking this
uh pen in this tail on
on a religion donkey i'm just
i'm just trying to save my ass you know
uh
but i feel like you know uh
and you know i get caught up in myself
and i'm not doing
it's not that i'm not doing i just
i i don't know sometimes i feel like
there's just a more like god wants to be
able to do things with me
and not pedophile stuff you know good
stuff
positive things not take me to a damn
marilyn manson's bro
i can't believe we went dude it was like
200 people and there was so small
and he cut twiggy ramirez open with a
damn beer bottle
and we lost our minds bro
god all right let's get some calls that
came in man let's hit one up right here
uh
here we go yo theo
this is stephen calling from reno nevada
what's up steven from
reno and reno is one city i would never
um accept blood in
you know i'll drop a pint off bro but if
they try to put anything in me in reno
son
you know i'm friggin i'll fly out before
i catch that bag son
gang homework just calling to inform you
that it's had a
the birth of my first son last night
congratulations
man dude this is positive stuff thank
you for this call man
you know i've been i've had a shovel out
for half of this episode and i've just
been digging us into a hole
that's beautiful man congrats stephen
you know he went full
term so he wasn't premature like that
gentleman nick
oh yeah early nick they called him in
this house growing up
you know and he'll he'll grow to 70
years probably but he'll never hit nine
months
you know he'll never hit full form baby
onward but uh just letting you know
that he was a healthy baby boy born
february 2nd at midnight
and uh we decided to go ahead and name
him theo
after you you know a little theodore and
just sharing that with you buddy uh gang
gang
gang gang bro
dude that's cool man thank you bro
thank you stephen man uh that's sweet of
you man
i love that little guy and i hope your
wife is doing it good and healthy and
congratulations man
you got a little son that's beautiful
man you know i think i i
know i you know i think about it more
and more often about getting a little
child that kind that's
that's my own and um
well look i'll give you some warnings
what can he look forward to as being a
theo it's
it can be tricky um
and he was born at midnight he's that
midnight snack
you know we had a kid in our
neighborhood growing up this kid brunch
hawkins was his name
and he was named uh he was born right at
10 30 a.m so they call him brunch
um but for your son
being theo he might wet the bed till
he's 32.
you know what i'm saying bro but it's
not really it's not a medical issue
it's just he's just nervous and scared
and that's how he is
um you know he believes in
you know he it might be seeing his
believing really
um what else um
he likes pasta but he doesn't go crazy
for it
i would say that he gonna like coconut
um what else he yeah he'll be
he'll definitely be flirty with the
ladies all ages
you know he likes to hug a woman make a
woman feel good
likes to feel the titties press against
his body against his the warm bags
against his body
um what else um
[Music]
he might have a nightlight for a while
man he might have a nightlight
still um
what else could i tell you about this
kid he you know he's gonna have that
that that freaking he gonna be dragging
that wagon baby he's got that booty of
meat
and that's gonna be you know it is what
it is and it ain't what it ain't
but if he sits down he means it
um he likes box lunches if you send him
to camp you can set him with a lunch
he's not going to complain he likes that
lunch he likes to open his little meal
and have his little things in there
and you can just cut the sandwich one
way you don't need to do it both ways
you know that's a little french for him
and we don't need to do all of that
what else he like he will have a teddy
bear but it might not be a teddy bear it
might be a different kind of
like kind of a stuffed animal or
something you know a different like
thing that he'll
sleep with you know i used to sleep with
a wooden spoon for a while
um you know just just he
he just might pick something different
uh
what else he'll like to ride his bike
but he's going to want to ride probably
with other kids he don't want to ride
alone really that much
it gets scary um
you know he's going to want to hear that
you love him
you know you're just going to want to
tell him and just make sure he hears you
you know just
just let him know that you love him
that's going to really make him feel
good
um what else
uh and if he has a brother make sure
they know their brothers make sure that
they look out for each other
you know or if he has a sister make sure
you tell them hey this is your sister
you
you know you guys are teammates you know
make sure you let him know that because
if nobody tells him he just won't know
and so he might feel by himself and his
siblings might feel
by their self um
but dude thank you bro thank you for
sharing that and congratulations to
little theodore bro
beautiful little fella out in the world
man you know and i hope he really has a
good existence and
and for me it's been a fun name to have
you know it's really been a fun name to
have so far so i'm happy to pass it on
let's get another call here that came in
um this is 985-664-9503
as always
hey deal my name is michael
from texas what's up michael
and texas yeah texas is a good place to
uh
honestly to hide a body man you know
what i'm saying you get about
west of uh of el paso with a shovel dog
they never gonna find your ex-wife dog
gang
i've called a couple times and you would
ask
questions and advice uh
about my addiction
um the day before last
or the night before last i i relapsed
i was just a little just a little over
100 days
clean and silver we're doing
really good and
with everything that i'm going through
you know i gave in
yeah the guilt of knowing that i gave in
and not saying anything to my family or
my fiance
or anyone it's getting to me
because i know how proud they were to me
like
it's all they talked about how proud
they were
i let them down i wanted to uh
i don't know if i really want advice or
whatever i mean
i'd love your advice for really i just
called to get this off my chest
to somebody because i literally have no
one
that i want to talk to about it and i
know you bet you've been there
gang brother um
thanks for thanks for the call man i
feel like literally like i'm listening
to myself right now
so thanks for the call you know i'll
just share what other people
in program have shared with me that you
know it's just a journey this is our
journey
and this is where we are
you know i had three years two years six
months
um dude 100 days man do you know how
bro that hundred days is man
that's the hardest bro getting that
first that hundred
days in a pandemic when people are
eating each other and people's you know
everybody people's buying guns and doing
traps in the yard
and freaking iwo jima and [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying people's eating
fireworks people's marrying her sister
jerry seinfeld dated a 17 year old
you're doing fine man
you're doing fine man uh
i'm gonna see if i can try to call you
right now actually bro let me see what i
can do here
hold on
hey hello hey michael what's up man it's
theo vaughn bro
what's up man where are you
i'm just chilling man uh i'm actually
calling out
it's crazy man because i'm doing this
episode and
we can leave this in the episode or we
can take it out it can be up to you
uh but yeah i was just talking about a
relapse like a month ago and
you know and i just i don't know i felt
uncomfortable talking about it and then
i got to your call
and it's just like well i could just
i could feel you man it's been rough
brothers
it's been a rough time but i'm getting
through it
yeah how you managing all right yeah i
just i mean after it happened i kind of
i mean i kind of went off you know the
deep in there for a little bit
uh i still haven't told anybody but uh
it it was rough for like a like a good
three days
and then finally i just told myself like
you did what you did
just you know you just take your head up
and go
amen i cannot believe i'm on the phone
with you right now jesus christ was
crazy
it was just man it was just small world
because i was like
scared to talk you know i was talking
about it on the on the episode and i was
like scared to talk about it and i'm
like how do i say this
and you know i felt like i was letting
some people down and like
um and i guess i felt like i was letting
myself down too
you know some uh you know
but then i got to your call and i was
like oh man um
yeah i'm not the only person that's you
know that's just kind of had this moment
you know
yeah it's it's a hard thing to go to you
know especially by yourself
with no one to talk to a lot of people
don't understand it
i feel like a lot of people don't get
you know that
that stuff so that's kind of why i
called you because i know that i mean i
don't really know what you've
messed with in the past but i knew that
you kind of had you know your issues
oh yeah that liquors i don't have a
problem with drinking but i get
if i if i you know i'll get scared i'm
gonna get by that white donkey bro
you know yeah exactly exactly i'll be
riding that i dude i'll be riding that
downhill donkey on roller skates
i was all into i was all into the pain
pill
that was my biggest my biggest thing
right there
it took me down for a long time damn you
do construction i got into heroin
damn bro yeah what are you doing dog
damn
you trying to be on that show the wire
you gotta tighten up
dude i just i was one of the people that
if i did it
i went i was all in if i was gonna do it
i want to do it all and do the most i
could
bro i could relate look every time i
meet somebody that smoke crack i'm
jealous of
yeah them i never got to school i don't
want to try it i know
i've always wanted to try but i'm scared
that's when that's when i guess that we
know maybe there's something
that's different in our head because
other people they'd be like somebody's
like
i smoke crack they'd be like okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna get out of this
walgreens before things get weird
but you and me bro i'll be like hey man
tell me what it was like what was it
like
exactly exactly that's funny man
um well how are you feeling now man are
you feeling better what are you feeling
like
well i mean if i mean once i got over
the guilt
uh i started feeling better yeah and
i've been
you know something else i've been doing
was really you know lean it on
on god and i know that sounds
corny to some people or whatever but not
to me
not today it doesn't bro well a lot of
people i mean i
you know i've seen over the years like a
bunch of people that you know that
you know go to prison or go to rehab
it's as soon as they get out there like
they're all into god and they'll buy one
a lot of them are just
i mean in my opinion they're putting on
a show i don't really think they
they believe it you know what i mean
yeah and i
i didn't want to come off like that but
yeah no i've really been leaning on
on god and trying to read the bible and
praying as much as i can
and it's kind of got me through it
yeah man it was in your show too dude
your show
i'm not trying to be a fanboy but
you don't i don't think you understand
like how much
your podcast
i'm trying not to cry dude i don't want
to sound like a dumbass but uh
your voice sounds tougher than my voice
i would say that easily
well i'm not tough brother i'm not so
but
every morning when i get up it's hard
for me to get up and it's hard for me to
put my clothes on to go to work and i
you know it's just hard because my job i
mean i'm a
gravedigger i bury people for a living
dang no
way bro are you serious yeah so it's oh
my god
damn bro you're working wow you're at
the sphincter of life bro you that great
dude
so sometimes it's like [ __ ] like
depressing
so i get up i'm depressed because of my
issues and i go to work and i'm
burying people like [ __ ] you i can't
catch a break
and then uh i ended up buying some of
these airpods
i put my airpods in one day
i knew that you had a show or a podcast
and i started listening to it and dude
that's all i do though
all day long on the tractor at
the gym i mean a tractor bearing dog
no you got to use a tractor to dig holes
they don't dig them by hand
some people do if they don't have money
but
like if they can't afford a tractor or
something i can understand that most
people dig them with a backup now
oh that's sellout [ __ ] bro i want that
hand dug baby
dude i've done it a few times and it's
it's a lot of work brother
a lot of work because i guess legally
you got to get them so low huh
yeah yeah i think the law requires here
to have
20 you know 24 inches of dirt on top of
like whatever you're buried in
[Music]
so we've got to dig down you're pretty
deep like five feet really
yeah oh yeah you could take yeah it's
supposed to be six but
you know we're trying to tell them i
don't think i've ever done one for six
feet
yeah that's what they said that's a word
yeah damn wow man that's crazy to even
think that i'm doing a podcast and
somebody that's digging graves is
listening to it bro
that's literally what i'm doing like
while i'm digging graves i'm listening
to your pocket
it's the only thing it's the only thing
and i'm not trying to be corny but it's
been the only thing that's
put a smile on my face made me laugh
like i remember one day
like a week or two ago i was listening
to one
i don't remember what you were talking
about but
you said something and dude i laughed
so hard i was crying i was pregnant
oh it was about uh you were talking
about joining a cult
you were talking to brendan about you're
joining a cult
oh yeah said something like you said i
was doing
dolphin danger for some [ __ ] dude i i
was crying i was laughing so hard
oh i was on that giddy up baby you know
yeah that one got me but i mean i just
love listening to it every day dude
thanks bro well i appreciate it man that
means a lot dude i'm glad that uh
you know i'm just glad that i'm glad
that when any of us have some little
thing in life to look forward to you
know and that's one reason why i feel
like
you know when you talked about god i was
like dang bro i want i just want
uh yeah you just never know when we can
be that for somebody any of us dude you
know so it's like that's what i hate
about
you know if i'm messed up or something
it's like am i missing out on those
chances
or any of us missing out on those
chances to be you know the person that
sees somebody at a store and gives them
a smile or the person that
answers the phone when somebody calls
and they're having a tough moment it's
just like
you know i just fall out of the lane of
that i fall out of that hov
lane you know yeah um
but well damn dawg you notice don't be
too hard on yourself man you know i'm
not trying to preach at you but
you know it's not all linear things
aren't all linear
you know yeah like i was like it's got
to be in a straight line i got to do it
you know
yeah that makes sense sometimes our
store we just don't know what our story
is man but
yeah that's how i feel now i just feel i
feel like i'm trying to figure out
like what i need to do next and how i'm
gonna do it yeah
sober yeah that's a tough thing to do
it's tough man and it's been a tough
time for people too man
i mean i've had friends that have died
i've had friends that are the most
soberest people ever they should be in a
damn
sober pageant bro they would win
they would win dang you know the top
prize they would win the crown of
um but they people falling off just it's
a tough time you know
yeah i've been having a berry like
literally bury people that i knew
i grew up with it's [ __ ] rough
it's rough like i'm you know people that
i grew up with that
went to school with i'm putting them in
the ground because of cobin
drug you know all kinds of [ __ ] damn
bruh
yeah dude that's why yeah man yeah look
well at least you have an excuse bro
i'm just podcasting and being hard on
myself you are hard on yourself bro you
need to
ease up a little bit i want to tell you
that i messaged you on instagram too
are you telling you yeah you messaged me
back one day and i [ __ ]
i bet had a heart attack dude don't have
a heart attack bro
no the bodies are gonna pile up at the
gate
i was one of those fans that i'm sure
you get a lot of i mean you know like
you'll
if you messed on the reply they [ __ ]
thank your buddies and
they [ __ ] yeah yeah oh that's a
dangerous game yeah people start sending
you everything recipes bro
they start sending you baby pictures and
[ __ ] like damn
it is intense dude that was that was me
when you wrote me back that day i was
like oh yeah well now we're friends hey
man how about this
then i had to dial it back a little bit
and then i was listening to one of your
shows
and you're kind of being hard on
yourself and i was like you know i'm
going to write him one more message to
tell him not
you know cheer up not be so hard on
himself
yeah you need to ease up man yeah i
don't know how you know
i don't know and it's funny i don't even
notice it it's just the way that i'm
built but i appreciate that man
maybe maybe this podcast will one day
end when i'm finally not hard on myself
you know
i think you just need to realize you're
uh you're a special
good person man like and i think you've
i think if you knew how good of a person
you are and how much you helped
you know everybody and people that
listen to you i think you wouldn't be so
hard on yourself
you helped thanks bro you helped me a
lot brother
well i appreciate you calling me bro
like
you don't know what this is doing to me
right now like it's
like when my phone started ringing i've
got your number uh
the hotline number yeah stored in my
phone
and when my when my phone started
ringing
i was in there with my fiance and i
grabbed the phone i took off running
the front door damn bruh she thought you
left her for another man bro
you better go there
you're gonna have to go back in there
man well dude i appreciate it man yeah i
think
you know i think we it's just funny we
all just need somebody to hear
we all just need to hear that somebody
thinks that we're important or this that
like we matter you know
and uh especially like when people that
struggle with alcoholism and that kind
of stuff man it's like damn i don't know
why those words just aren't built into
our skin sometimes um
but look man i'll be in touch with you
man i'ma hit you on my private line
don't be calling me all the time but uh
dude i won't but i'll say hey that would
mean the world to me man if you really
did that would mean the world to me well
you got it bro you know i feel like at
least we can uh
hey you know two alcoholics talking to
each other man that's how the whole
program
started there we go so
well don't be hard on yourself man i
love you bro i love you too man
you i appreciate you calling me all
right you bet man be good dog
all right i'll talk to you soon all
right peace baby
man bro hell
i don't even know what the world is man
yeah man i don't even know why that made
me kind of emotional bro i think
you know it's just i don't know
i think we all i think we all just want
to hate we all just want to he
we all want to hear somebody
i don't know we all want to hear
somebody tell us that we're okay you
know or we all want to
man i don't even know man i should get
me some type of way right now bro
damn no homo for real bro no cat man
but
yeah i don't know we all just
we're all just trying to be okay and and
somehow this world has made it kind of
tough sometimes
or maybe it hasn't i don't know i don't
know
i don't know man but
but that's the power of people i know
that
you know i know you could call somebody
and you could both leave the call
feeling like somebody cares and i think
you know uh
i think that's powerful and that those
are moments where i think god shows up
bro
in those little moments where somebody
feels like when you feel in your heart
bro when you feel that
feeling inside of you just like care
bears are [ __ ] swimming through your
veins dog when you
feel
like the world comes out of usually i
feel like the world goes in
it's coming on me it's but when you feel
like the world comes out of you
for just brief moments man that's where
i find god man
right there
uh let me see if anybody needs a call
right now
i think man we did a lot i've been the
[ __ ] i've been through a lot man i'm
gonna need some more
water man damn
but yeah if anybody is out there
struggling man i guess the hard thing is
yeah just saying like i'm
i'm i'm i'm struggling or i didn't i
didn't
do first place you know i didn't win
i didn't you know i'm not sober i'm not
champion i'm not uh
you know the pressure i just i don't
know i don't know man i don't know what
i'm trying to say man
i'm just trying to say if you having a
tough day man i love you bro
am female bro and
and if you're not having a tough day and
you're feeling good then
you know you never know when you could
be that little bit of light that that
reflects off somebody
and makes them feel warm
you know no homo dog for real bro praise
god dawg so
um damn i'm gonna hear about this shitty
jiu jitsu dog damn bruh
they gonna be hard scarfin your boy out
there
but keep your head up out there michael
thanks for the call man and thanks for
the kind words dude
yeah i'm still kind of a real just
overwhelmed emotion but i don't know
what it's about
you know sometimes when i feel emotional
i have to like kind of like feel it
and like i'll try and talk to myself
like okay
are you happy you know are you
and then i'll be like maybe i'm happy
and i'm like okay why are you happy
okay i'm happy because
and i'm happy because
no it's not really happiness because
then my emotions start to fade away and
i can tell if they fade away then i'm
not on the trail
so they're going to be like are you
surprised
sometimes the word will come in my head
am i surprised
yes so now i answer yes i'm surprised
and then why are you surprised
and then i'm surprised because
i guess i'm surprised because people
care
so you know i'm surprised because people
because i think you know when i was
young and [ __ ]
growing up i felt like nobody cared bro
and you put up all these things inside
of you because nobody cares you know and
then
you happen upon a small moment where
somebody really cares you know
and uh
and it just disproves everything you
thought you ever knew about the world
man and that is
surprising so that's how i work
through when i'm having like a emotional
thing like where i figure out what i'm
feeling i have to ask myself
are you happy are you
um shameful or you you know you have to
ask and then
if it still feels it's almost like a
metal detector if it still feels like
you're getting a little bit of a feeling
then
i'll say well why am i happy or why am i
ashamed or why
am i um mad you know and then sometimes
i can
i can badger up those feelings
[Music]
yeah yeah you also see these badgers bro
these things
these [ __ ] are for real out here oh
oh that one's on that cocaine but that
was on that dust son
um all right man what else do we have
today we got nothing else man but i'm
i'm just i don't know man i'm happy to
be with you guys you guys be good to
yourselves man you deserve it and thank
you for being a part of my life man
i really mean it i needed it today and
boom you were there man damn
you never ever know what can happen man
uh let's leave out on this tune man
i love this tune and this man really did
it right
and uh this is from
josh kelly my baby in the band hold me
my lord sing down the sun
[Music]
shine down your song
so that it might
guide me back home
[Music]
we all need some light
on the darkest of days
[Music]
so that we might
come on not lose our way
[Music]
it's a holy holy holy lord holding my
heart
down on my knees asking you to hold me
hold me hold me with your
loving arm come on josh kelly
all that i need
time's even cruel
[Music]
make way for a brand new star
brand new start baby come on
[Music]
holy holy holy lord holding my heart
down on my knees asking you to hold me
hold me hold me with your love and
know come on all that i need
[Music]
i need you to hold me
i wanna walk with you in the light
i want to sing with you through
the night help me believe
holy holy lord holding my heart
i'm down on my knees asking you to hold
me
hold me hold me with your loving
arm come on baby hold me all that i need
oh
come
it don't on me mine
i'm asking you to hold me man come on
no homo bro for real for real bro uh
that's hold me my lord and that is from
his new album my baby in the band
mr josh kelly and if that ain't a song
then i don't know a song man um
yeah sorry i kind of been leaking out on
this one bro but
you know some days that's the way it
works and uh
i guess i'm a little embarrassed kind of
but i'm not ashamed
you know and um
yeah and i love you guys man gang bro